[Music]
hello and welcome to chinese whispers
with me cindy yu every episode i'll be
talking to journalists experts and
long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more
there'll be a smattering of history to
catch you up on the background knowledge
and some context how do the chinese see
these issues
china's property market accounts for
somewhere between 20 and 29 of the whole
country's gdp
the never ending rise of residential
blocks were how ordinary people like my
family could see and touch the
miraculous economic growth that the
country was going through
but in recent months the property market
hasn't been so hot in fact it's
contracted seven percent uh compared to
this time last year and that's a big
drag on the gdp as a whole which is now
looking more like three percent growth
this year if that
so what's going on what is causing this
slump in the housing market i'm joined
today by george magnus who's an
economist and author of red flags a book
which looks at all the underlying
economic problems in xi jinping's
economy
together with lulu chen who is a
bloomberg journalist looking at real
estate in asia
so george and lulu thank you so much for
joining me um lulu let's start with your
story recently you reported on a protest
by homeowners across 80 cities in china
in which they simply refused to pay
their mortgages tell us about it
yeah so i think a little bit of context
here for audiences who are not in china
this refusal to pay mortgages is quite
different from the subcri subprime
mortgage crisis that we saw in the us a
few years ago
it's not so much
issue of financial stress on these home
owners part it's more because a lot of
these construction projects actually as
of today there's more than 300 of these
projects they simply haven't been been
completed and so as a homeowner you're
sitting here and you're paying mortgages
first uh projects that have not been
built that have not been completed and
you don't know when the developers are
gonna ever start construction again and
so that's really what started this
movement it started in the home base for
china's porcelain factory and it just
snowballed from there after
other home owners saw that they they
actually grabbed attention and it came
to they actually managed to get some
some reaction from the government after
months and years of uh petitions
yeah and the situation in china is that
more than 90 of properties in 2021 were
pre-sales so because you've got all
these new builds coming up people are
actually selling them and buying them
before they're actually built but as you
say a lot of them are not being
completed actually i've got a stat here
that says between 20 to 30 and 2020 only
60 of these pre-sold homes were
completed so george it's not a happy
scene but before we delve further in can
you give listeners an idea of just how
important the real estate industry is to
the chinese economy
yes of course um
except i think many people will be
familiar with
a paper that was written by
ken rogoff and uh colleague
uh probably about um
i don't know a year maybe 15 18 months
ago now
and this kind of now infamous number of
29 of gdp is being kind of quoted all
over the place
um so their estimate basically is not
just about housing construction
but also housing services like renting
brokering and so on and so forth
but also
the kind of consumer cyclicals that go
into new apartments like white goods and
so on and also the commodities that
enter into the construction
of apartments so their estimate was that
um that on a kind of an annual kind of
flow basis that uh the real estate
sector accounts for about 29 of gdp some
people have kind of queried whether
that's a little bit too high uh but even
the kind of skeptics think that you know
we're still talking about a sector uh
that's contributing between a fifth and
22 23
uh of gdp so it's um it's
it's a really really big part of the
chinese economy and whenever people talk
about china's over investment or the
fact that you know it's too investment
heavy and not enough kind of consumption
in in the structure of the economy
that that investment is first and
foremost really about um construction in
housing and
to some degree commercial buildings and
infrastructure
but a lot of it is housing
and lulu what's interesting about this
mortgage buyers protest is that the
government's response since has been um
not what you might expect can you tell
us about what they have done in response
i mean well i should say we're recording
this on the 19th of july so
the response so far
right so so as of this week the latest
reporting that we have is that um the
the banking regulators have told banks
to the lenders to start issuing credit
to distressed developers the ones that
qualify so they can complete these
projects also as of yesterday we also
reported that they're thinking of giving
a
so-called mortgage holiday to these home
buyers um saying that if their uh their
homes have not been completed then
these buyers can extend their their
payments for for a period of time
without official uh affecting their
credit scoring so it the reaction so far
has been i think this has been one of
the most successful petitions if you if
you will um
among recent years where you've actually
seen these people um
voiced their demand and actually
gotten some kind of response that wasn't
just a straight down crackdown from the
regulators and some say this is because
that
these petitioners represent uh
they do represent china's middle class
to some extent and it's not just your um
in the previous years like villagers
whose lands got taken away that kind of
protest so the middle class has more i
would say more influence and more voice
when it comes to these matters and maybe
that's why we're seeing this reaction
so george tell us then what is the
problem why are these developers so
under kosher at the moment
well of course the um i mean the the the
de numong in the real estate sector has
been going on
pretty much since last year right so
when the um
um when the so-called red lines were
introduced which were regulations the
government introduced in uh 2020 if i'm
not mistaken
um
that basically imposed constraints on
the ability of china's property
developer
development companies
uh to borrow and they regulated their
balance sheet leverage and so on and so
forth
um arguably i mean this might have
happened anyway but arguably this these
restrictions were the trigger
um that basically catapulted uh you know
the crisis in evergrand which is the the
world's biggest um uh property developer
borrower um and um
not quite the biggest property developer
in china but certainly the second
biggest one but also there are a lot of
other developers that have been um
found out so to speak in terms of having
uh overreached so they've been about um
18 defaults um in china's property
development sector
uh on uh you know tens of billions of
dollars of um mostly foreign bonds
foreign currency bonds
um but this is just the kind of tip of
the iceberg really because the the
property sector itself
is now uh
obviously rolling over um i mean as uh
lulu said you know so these restrictions
affecting homeowners
uh have been very very uh quickly uh
introduced
with the relaxation of restrictions and
increased borrowing to developers i mean
these are essential things that have to
be done in order to stop the contagion
because the government's really on a
kind of a no-win situation here if they
if they come to the relief of homeowners
who
rightly are kind of hacked off by paying
mortgages on
properties that are not being uh built
anymore because of developer problems
and they might you know they and they
begin to pay mortgage debt from the
initial deposit they make on an
unfinished building i mean that's the
pre-sale model uh in china's housing
market um obviously they're very unhappy
about that and um if if the government
kind of goes overboard in helping these
people
then it's surely kind of a green light
for lots of other people to say well why
not you know we'll we'll stop paying our
mortgages too if we can't um you know if
we having problems getting uh closure on
our own properties but on the other hand
if they don't
really come to the relief of um of
homeowners then the whole pre-sale model
which as you said in your introduction
um accounted for about 90 of sales in
2021
is shot and uh you know that could send
a new very sharp deflationary shockwave
into the property market in which you
see demand weaken because nobody's going
to buy from developers anymore so or not
certainly from bankrupt developers
so demand for property will weaken
prices will come down that'll we can
demand and so on and so forth so
um it's um it's a hiding to nothing
really for for the regulatory
authorities and for the government
almost whatever they do uh they're going
to be you know potential instability um
it's a question of how they're going to
be able to manage that
george in my understanding china's
property market has boomed incredibly
since housing reform in the 90s before
which you know people like my parents
were being allocated flats to live in by
the government or by their employers
rather than buying their own personal
place so the last two decades there's
been a massive boom and am i right in
thinking that a lot of these developers
funded that through high investment but
investment that was basically from
borrowed money and so creating this kind
of circle of high sales high demand high
investment high borrowing but the
government with those red lines said
that's quite unsustainable and actually
could go wrong very quickly which is i
guess what we're seeing now but the
government brought forward in a
controlled way except it's not so
controlled yeah it i mean so the the the
pre-sale model of housing sales is a bit
of a ponzi scheme
so obviously the developers
you know they rake in hordes of cash
from existing customers
for properties that haven't been built
yet
and they use that cash to fund
construction of homes to new customers
um if you see what i mean and so you
know it becomes that's fine as long as
confidence is high as long as you know
investors in the develop developer
companies are confident in their debt
management
so long as you know the economic
environment is good
so
the thing about real estate is
everything is intensely pro-cyclical
right everything that's good
feeds on itself in the boom and
everything that's bad feeds on itself in
the downturn you don't have any of this
kind of conscious cyclical
um
tendencies where there are kind of
offsets to
um to kind of to manage the the real
estate cycle in this sense i think it's
a bit of a wake-up call because
for i mean china's had kind of property
ups and downs before um no question
about it not really in prices
but certainly in transactions volumes
and in you know sales and construction
so on um but there's never really been
anything quite like this before um and i
think that the the idea that china might
be immune from
your bog standard you know real estate
boom and bust i think is uh is being
kind of blown up really
lulu did you want to come in on that
um yeah just to add in terms of how we
got here so
evergrande was really you know the the
first first uh developer that showed it
started showing signs of trouble and
with the size and scope that we use for
evergrand is this is the world's most
indebted developer they were sitting on
300 billion of liabilities and with the
three red lines what that was originally
uh aimed at
capping their credit um against the
central bank the when the initiatives
first came down it really was
um the broader
back setting of this is xi jinping he's
taking a personal uh interest in
championing common prosperity in china
and property has been one of the things
that has really been driving the wealth
gap in china so in order to to close
that gap and also
to end this never-ending property price
rising cycle in china um banks were
asked the central banking regulator was
asked to actually step in and try to
limit the the liability liabilities and
credit that these developers had and uh
fast forward a year now all of these
developers including ones that used to
be considered um safe like country
garden and even banky are now are now
really in trouble and their their bonds
are being selled off like crazy in the
in the debt market um
so that entire high-yield credit market
that used to be predominantly chinese
property developers is essentially gone
there's no debt issuance so these
developers have no channel for money
raising at this point and and there are
no
sales revenue essentially because of the
covet lockdowns and people are asking
like when is china's property market
going to bottom out i think until we get
a lift in the covit restrictions and
until xi jinping
stops saying his motto his famous motto
is housing is for living not for uh
speculation so if you have this as the
overall guidance i think regulators are
gonna use that as the as the benchmark
and and
no matter how many small trickling
policies we're seeing from the local
government it's not enough to save a
person who's already in the icu
yeah and lula can you talk about kovid
what is the impact of the xero covert
policy on that is it just from a
consumer demand perspective
well it affects mobility it affects the
economy so if property buyers are seeing
the economy
starting to slow down or even fall then
you would not want to invest in property
given falling prices and a slowing
economy it really really clouds the
future prospects right so
this loss of confidence and also the
fact that people can't go on site and
construction is stalling so it's almost
like a chain effect where that that's
causing the the slowdown in sales
and people are paying mortgages all the
time of course that's the problem yeah
yeah and i guess i guess people have
struggled in the last few years you know
there's no furlough scheme or anything
like that so you're eating away at your
savings you're maybe not earning as much
as you usually would or you might have
even lost your job and
that's all going to have an impact on on
the property market i guess um lulu can
i ask about the demand from um consumers
here because george has talked about
this kind of virtuous cycle that's
caused the boom in the last few decades
the chinese demand for housing um i feel
like there's a cultural thing here
because um you and i know you know if
you're a young man looking to have a
wife you're looking to start a family
you have to have a house
and that's something that a lot of
parents are very happy to help with i
think one hsbc study put it in 2017
found that 40 of millennials had help
from the bank of mum and dad in china
at the same time house prices are going
up in cities like beijing the house
price to income ratio is something like
14 fold which is you know ridiculous uh
unaffordability so is that what has
driven as well the housing boom over the
last few decades this kind of cultural
demand for housing does this cultural
demand to have home ownership
i think that's a
multiple factors first of all in the
past few decades population was we still
had
population moving from rural areas
smaller cities into into the big city so
in the backdrop with the backdrop of
urbanization um
we we there was real demand but right
now china's urbanization level is around
65 percent and it's very similar to what
you have in developed economies like the
us or europe at 75 percent
and on top of that our population growth
is slowing and probably going to drop in
the future um so the demand will come
down at some point and i think
maybe
even without the three red lines china's
property sector was bound for a turning
point and and the the policies that came
in
were just expedited everything
and george
speaking of the three red lions do you
think that was the right way of dealing
with what they saw was an overheated
market or could they have done something
else that maybe would have prevented
this last 12 months of turmoil
well i think you know i mean it's uh
yeah i mean
the problem with
just rampant growth in debt or the
creation of you know infinite amount of
liabilities on the balance sheet is that
at some point it has to
come to an end i mean because it's just
no way to run a business so to speak
um and um and greater kind of regulatory
capital and restraints on balance sheet
leverage and so on and so forth i mean
these are all
you know quite common
tools which regulatory authorities use
to try to contain
indebtedness
so
yeah i mean the trouble is with these
things as is you know that
and in this sense you know the chinese
experience i don't think is so different
from anybody else's because we went
through the same thing in the 2000s in
the
um in the so-called western world you
know leading to the to the gfc to the
great financial crisis
is if you don't regulate well or
regulate or supervise properly during
the boom years you end up having to do
it at the worst possible moment
and that's exactly what's happened so
you know the imposition of these
restrictions
uh was made at a time when you know the
sector was probably you know
right for a fall
and and it exacerbated it and even the
now of course the relaxation of
these red line restrictions or the kind
of greater forbearance which has been
introduced into the observance of those
restrictions is not really going to save
the developers not really going to save
the sector because
um yeah just too many fundamentals i
mean you talk about the sort of cultural
preference for for housing which is
surely um i mean i'm not sure whether
it's uniquely chinese because high rates
of home ownership are not you know are
common in the uk us and so on and so
forth
um but i do think that a lot of the
fundamentals that drew that kind of lay
behind
the success of the housing market
expansion in china which are
household formation
working age population expansion
migration
[Music]
you know the demographics were right
lots of investment
etc etc i mean these things basically
all in their own little ways uh you know
of cumulatively turning and so they're
now contributing to a much more sober
outlook so at some point uh hopping back
to what um you and lulu were discussing
really about covet
um
you know if at some point the zero
covered policy were to be miraculously
abandoned
um or kind of phased out then sure you
know we will see a bounce back in you
know lots of
indicators of the housing market and
other services as well but that we
shouldn't be seduced into thinking that
that means that you know that it's all
over that's just
the natural kind of reaction there are
kind of probably decade long drags on
the property market which i think
are going to take a long time to
dissipate
lulu one um analyst i came across had an
interesting take um he said our base
case is that regulators will succeed in
containing the crisis by strong-arming
state-owned banks into supporting
troubled developers so that was really
interesting because it betrayed this
view that the state will always bail
these developers out is that do you
think this analyst was right in thinking
that will the state bail them out again
i mean we're already seeing signs of it
so far in the mortgage uh protest
right i think
well right now that's the billion dollar
question which is how is the government
going to get out of this mess and i
think no matter what the solution is
the banks are going to play a
significant role in this because 30 to
40 percent of bank loans are tied to the
property market and then also on top of
that you have um
30 to 40 percent of local government
land sales also tied to
tied to land sales so so
it's essentially too big to fail this
market and
people are always saying oh where does
the money come from the banks have money
and and there's that expectation for the
banks to just keep printing money or
keep taking down the taking up all this
debt and and kicking the bucket down the
road um i think for for the banks right
now um
there's um
the estimates in terms of how how much
the bad loans are um so there's a bit of
a guessing game if you look at china's
total outstanding mortgages it's around
38 trillion yen
that's excluding the the
team like the non-risky mortgage loans
um and then anz had an estimation saying
that they think about 1.5 trillion yuan
of mortgages could be affected so that's
up about four percent but if you look a
little bit closer
so bloomberg intelligence our own
analysis says that of the top 10 banks
listed here in hong kong the bigger ones
their the impact on them is going to be
relatively small and probably only
0.01
of their mortgages are going to become
bad debt
but the smaller rural and city
commercial banks have taken on more risk
and more of these um
risky mortgages and and they could be
affected a lot more so the mpl ratio
could be a lot higher for the smaller
banks
and george you mentioned foreign
creditors as well should they be worried
that they're not going to be paid back
because i mean i wouldn't be surprised
if the government just says okay pay
back your chinese creditors first don't
worry about the foreign ones
oh sure um i mean i think uh well by now
i don't know i mean last time i checked
i think the
implied interest rates and a lot of um
high yield you know developer debt was
like you know
35 45
i don't know on some of these
instruments so i think you know
it's going to take it's going to take a
long time and something you know pretty
spectacular for foreigners to
return to to this market so
the issue really i think is really
whether uh you know what happens to the
debt in the domestic market i mean the
foreign currency debt is pretty much a
um i mean it's you know
as i said before i think you know we've
already had close to a score of defaults
um
already and there's probably going to be
more so
that's a kind of a write-off i think um
i think most probably investors would
have
pretty much you know kiss goodbye to
that um but it's quite important what
happens of course in the domestic market
and um
um
and and really how policy kind of
evolves really and how they how they're
going to deal with it i mean a lot of
these
numbers uh that we kind of looking at is
a sort of snapshot in terms of you know
how many properties are affected by not
being completed how much mortgage debt
is involved you know which banks are
involved and so on these things are they
look kind of manageable if you look at
them like taking a picture of them but
actually the issue really is contagion
right it's it's really that the
contagion is something that you know if
it actually happened it becomes very
very difficult to control
and i think that the um the deciding
factor almost uh not the maybe a an
important deciding factor really will be
how uh the authorities
deal with
the the boycotters you know the mortgage
boycotters
um so
as i said before you know if it's too
generous treatment you know everybody
will want to join in if it's not
generous enough then the um the pre-sale
housing sale model is shot and it could
be very destabilizing um but it's um
it's you know
that there isn't really a kind of i mean
you know chinese government likes to
talk about win-win situations this is
really lose-lose there's no there's no
there's no real winner in this at all um
i mean it's and it's just one of those
it's one of those things that happens at
the end of a property boom property is a
vicious asset i mean beautiful when
everything's going well
but it's pretty vicious when when things
grow into a hole because then lots of
things that are previously uncorrelated
all fall together um and that's kind of
what we're beginning to see here i think
and george i just wanted to check with
you i mean you've suggested this already
but you do think that this one is worse
than anything the market has seen before
because warnings have sounded about
china's housing boom for you know a
decade now all the way back to 2011
there were estimates of millions of
empty properties talk of ghost towns
there's housing bubble but do you think
that this time is the real deal
uh well
it's true there have been uh
lots of you know sort of false storms
shall we say before about um you know
obviously ghost town ordos you know and
other places
um and a lot of the kind of problems
were concentrated in sort of tier three
and tier four
so lower administratively important
cities whereas
there's never really been kind of as far
as i can remember specifically any kind
of major crisis in any of the kind of
big cities or tier two cities
um but i think this is different because
this is not really about whether there's
you know spare capacity or whether we're
you know people have a sort of a
difference of measurement about
emptiness because a lot a lot of empty
apartments are or were pre-sold
apartments there's just nobody was
actually living in them even though
somebody was owning them
um but i think this is potentially
problematic because it's about mortgages
you know so i've seen the pbc number of
i think lulu mentioned now about 38 or
39 trillion won in kind of mortgage debt
although i've also seen total total
household debt uh at around 60 to 70
trillion so there may be lots of things
that are kind of built into that which
may be
um i don't know possibly second
mortgages or other forms of personal
liability um but when you're talking
about the biggest charge on most
people's and particularly here the
middle class is balance sheet
um then um i mean that that's
that's a really important kind of
threshold to cross because actually
people's behavior uh can change uh quite
dramatically when they feel
um you know that their housing security
is being compromised or prejudiced
yeah absolutely well that leads really
nicely on to my final question um to you
lulu because 70
of household wealth in china is in real
estate people just put their money in
that instead of saving it elsewhere or
putting it in stocks so what are the
implications not just economic but for
for for your ordinary chinese citizen
who's pre who's bought pre-bought a a
property that hasn't been developed or
um has their money in housing lots of
housing that's going to now crash you
know what is the implication for
ordinary people and in turn what is the
political implication for a country like
china government like china's
yeah just based on the interviews that
my colleagues have done these few days
they're talking to these homeowners and
mortgage boycotters
and what they're really saying is it's
kind of shattered they're they have this
idea of the world what it was like and
life was always going upwards and
tomorrow is going to be better than
yesterday and that's kind of the
mentality that people born in the late
70s
especially 80s 90s generation they've
never seen that bad right
they've never
experienced a full economic cycle and
this is probably the first time the this
generation of people who are just coming
into their 30s they're buying property
and they're experiencing this so it
really changes their world view of what
life is going to be like for for them in
the future and also
really cast doubt on whether
you know
the the economy and the future of the
country is going to be as they
they envisioned when they were growing
up especially coming just in the
aftermath of the shanghai lockdown which
i think it was a wake-up call for a lot
of middle-class chinese people yeah it
was also
an eye-opener especially for a lot of
the
affluent urban urban people who
especially in shanghai because
if you had said this at the beginning of
the year a lot of people would just
flatly tell you it would be impossible
that they would lock down shanghai like
that yeah absolutely well george magnus
and lulu chen thank you so much for
joining chinese whispers
[Music]
you